>>> WHERE ARE OUR COFFEES?
WASN'T AN INTERN SUPPOSED TO
GRAB THEM?
>> LET ME CHECK.
LOOKS LIKE THEY SAID, WE DON'T
GET COFFEES FOR LITTLE BITCH
BOYS.
>> AGAIN?
>> COME ON, MAN, ARE WE LITTLE
BITCH BOYS?
>> WE NEED TO LEARN HOW TO STICK
UP FOR OURSELVES.
>> WE CAN'T KEEP GETTING BULLIED
BY INTERNS.
I THINK I KNOW SOMEONE WHO CAN
HELP US.
>> I'M KURT LIGHTNING, AND I
KNOW WHY YOU ALL SIGNED UP FOR
MY CLASS.
YOU'RE SEARCHING FOR CONFIDENCE.
THE CONFIDENCE OF NOT ONLY
KNOWING YOU CAN DEFEND YOURSELF,
BUT THAT YOU'RE SOMEBODY WORTH
DEFENDING.
SAY IT WITH ME, I AM WORTH IT.
>> I AM WORTH IT.
>> SAY IT LIKE YOU MEAN IT.
>> I AM WORTH IT!
>> FEEL IT!
YOU, GET UP HERE.
WHAT'S YOUR NAME, SON?
>> JOHN.
>> OH, JOHN, I CAN HEAR IT IN
YOUR VOICE.
YOU FEEL SMALL, DON'T YOU, SON?
>> YES.
>> YOU GOT TO OWN IT, SON, OWN
YOUR TRUTH.
>> I FEEL SMALL.
>> BUT YOU'RE NOT SMALL.
PUT YOUR HANDS UP.
I AM GOING TO STRIKE, AND WHEN I
STRIKE, YOU DEFLECT, AND I WANT
YOU TO HIT ME BACK, AND WHEN YOU
DO, IMAGINE I'M THE VOICE IN
YOUR HEAD TELLING YOU YOU AREN'T
WORTH IT.
BECAUSE WHAT ARE YOU?
>> I AM WORTH IT!
>> NOW, ARE YOU READY?
>> I AM RED --
>> DUDE!
>> TOO SLOW, FATSO.
WHO'S NEXT?
>> TOM, ARE YOU OKAY?
WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT TO HIM?
>> YOU'RE NEXT.
>> I'M --
>> WHY ARE YOU SO AFRAID, SON?
>> YOU PUNCHED MY FRIEND, AND
I'M WORRIED HE'S DEAD.
>> YOU'RE AFRAID YOUR FATHER WAS
RIGHT.
>> I DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
HIM.
>> THAT'S NOT AN OPTION BECAUSE
YOUR FATHER WAS WRONG.
>> KURT, PLEASE.
>> YOU ARE A MAN, AND I NEED YOU
TO TELL HIM.
>> HOW?
>> CLOSE YOUR EYES.
>> OH!
>> DIDN'T STAND A CHANCE, BUCKO!
HE REALLY CLOSED HIS EYES.
>> IS THIS WHAT THE CLASS IS?
>> YOU HAVE BEEN SCARED YOUR
WHOLE LIFE.
>> OH, NO.
>> YOU LOST YOUR MOTHER AT A
YOUNG AGE.
>> THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
>> BECAUSE YOUR FATHER WASN'T
THERE TO PROTECT HER.
>> YOU'RE MAKING STUFF UP, MAN.
>> AND I'M HERE TO SHOW YOU A
MAN CAN DEFEND THE ONES HE
LOVES.
I WANT YOU TO PUNCH THIS WOMAN
RIGHT HERE.
>> NO WAY.
>> AND I WILL DEFLECT YOUR
STRIKE.
>> WHY ARE WE DOING THIS?
>> BECAUSE I WANT TO SHOW YOU A
REAL MAN DEFENDS THE WOMAN HE
LOVES.
>> BUT YOU'RE POSITIVE YOU WILL
BLOCK IT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> BECAUSE IF I HIT THIS WOMAN,
SHE WILL DIE.
>> PUNCH HER OR I'M GOING TO
PUNCH YOU.
>> OKAY.
YOU GOT IT.
>> NICE TRY, BITCH.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> BOOM, SHELLY, YOU DID THAT
DAMN THING.
>> DID A REVOLVER COME OUT OF
YOUR PANTS?
WHY DO YOU HAVE THIS?
>> BECAUSE I LIVE IN FEAR.
WHY DO YOU THINK I'M IN THIS
CLASS?
>> GIVE ME THAT.
>> WHOA!
>> YOU WANT TO PLAY A GAME?
>> WHAT?
RUSSIAN ROULETTE?
>> FEELING LUCKY, SLICK?
>> COME ON, DON'T DO IT!
>> AHH!
>> ARE YOU OKAY?
OH, MY GOD.
>> GREAT WORK, GUYS.
YOU FINALLY STOOD UP FOR
YOURSELVES.
>> WHAT THE HELL YOU TALKING
ABOUT?
>> I THINK SOMEBODY OWES YOU
SOME COFFEES.
>> WHAT?
THE INTERNS.
>> HEY, GUYS.
AFTER YOU SHOVED THAT OLD LADY
INTO THE TROPHY CASE, I FINALLY
RESPECT YOU.
>> THANKS, GUYS.
>> AND HERE'S YOUR COFFEE.
>> AHH!